hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
one interesting dictum of Epicurus is
moral theory that we find running
throughout his works almost
word-for-word although sometimes
translated a little bit differently in
the english runs one cannot live
pleasantly without live incredibly
honorably and justly now that's a very
interesting thing to say for its own
sake and this is really what Epicurus
thinks in terms of the conditions for
the good life the life of happiness the
life that is actually as pleasant as
possible so what is there this
connection between pleasantness or
pleasure and living prudently living
honorably or we'll talk about exactly
what that means in a moment and living
justly he gives us some explanation of
two of these he doesn't give us much
explanation of the middle of one so what
we want to do is look at what each of
these terms actually means not just
lexically in terms of the greek and how
we would translate it but what it means
for Epicurus within his his moral theory
within his ethical system and then we
want to think about how these would
conduce to actually living
Pleasant life and now when he's talking
about living a pleasant life he doesn't
just mean one moment you might actually
translate this better as a pleasant
lifestyle a you know sustained process
of living that goes on and is structured
in a certain way there's certain ways of
living according to Epicurus that may in
fact that contains some pleasures or
pursue some pleasures but will not be
there for a pleasant life in any sort of
full sense so let's look first at this
discussion about living prudently the
greek term for that is fro nemo's and we
often translate phronesis as prudence or
practical wisdom it's an understanding
of what is actually good for human
beings what is bad for human beings how
to you know go about attaining our ends
how to you know do the right things in
situations not just right and a sort of
you know sense of fulfilling our duties
but right for us as well that's going to
conduce to our our living well and
enjoying ourselves for Epicure so from
your mouth you know living fro me most
is living according to practical wisdom
understanding the natures of pleasures
and pains is going to be of the essence
of that for Epicurus understanding
what's really valuable in life and what
is just based on what he calls
groundless or empty or vain opinions
that's all going to be part of phronesis
for him he actually says in the letter
to men osseous that the beginning and
greatest good for human beings is in
fact prudence prudence is a more
precious thing than even philosophy from
it Springs all the other virtues and
prudence is what actually teaches us
this dictum so this is not only about
prudence this is actually stemming from
prudence we'll look at that we know why
that's so important in a moment this
other term kalos in in greek
there's this this moral value sometimes
we translate it as beauty or fineness or
honorable Ness or you know it's sort of
intrinsic value and it's difficult to
get across it means different things in
different situations but Kalos in the
the adjective sense to live according to
that sort of standard to live a the
light of Kalos means to live a life well
to live a life you might say in a
certain graceful way in a way that's
appropriate in a way that makes sense in
a way that is adapted to what you know
is is finest for human beings the
opposite of that would be an ugly life a
life that is full of intrinsic badness a
life that's in many respects damaged or
it you know not fulfilling its its its
goals or its ends you know a life that
is stunted so he doesn't really tell us
much more about this in the writings
that we have preserved by him but you
know we could probably extrapolate some
things from other passages he will tell
us quite a bit about justice in fact so
much that I'm creating another core
concept video specifically on Epicurus
as discussions and conception of justice
but he says that we have to live justly
that is de caios in accordance with the
norms of justice now this is going to
include for him living according to you
might say a certain basic morality that
has to hold among all human beings if
we're going to live together in any sort
of harmonious way it also means
following the rules of the particular
society with with with within which one
lives provided those rules don't
actually go against these more
overarching norms of justice and
provided those rules are oriented toward
some sort of what he calls mutual
usefulness that is they they actually
benefit the people that are involved
with them so it totally
just regime one would not be living
justly by living in accordance with its
norms as a matter of fact you could be
living justly precisely by contesting
those norms but for the most part in
most societies and within the structure
of most relationships so within groups
because relationships are going to be
very important for for Epicurus there
are certain you might say basic
standards that we have to follow he also
says in the sovereign in the principle
doctrines that whenever one of these is
lacking the living prudently living
honorably or well living justly it's
impossible to live a pleasant life one
one could be for example living wisely
or living well and justly but not living
wisely and it wouldn't be a fully
Pleasant life so why is that the case
why are all three of these necessary why
do they in a certain respect call upon
and interpenetrate each other again I
think that will probably get more
mileage out of looking at the role of
prudence and justice than them thinking
about this particular standard because
Epicurus doesn't tell us that much about
it why can't you live a pleasant life
without living crudely
now what would it mean to live prudently
like we put here it mean to live in
accordance with practical wisdom does
that mean that you actually have to be
yourself a prudent person not
necessarily you could be guiding
yourself say during the years of
adolescence under the guidance the
tutelage of somebody else who's got more
you know to offer in that respect
somebody who's got more experience
somebody who actually has cultivated
practical wisdom hopefully you would
acquire it in turn but perhaps if you
had the right kind of friends and the
right kind of environment you wouldn't
necessarily need to develop prudence for
yourself
still it probably would be better if you
don't have prudence to rely upon well
you're going to start making dumb
decisions
short-sighted decisions
pleasures and pains if you don't fully
understand what truly is pleasant and
what just appears to be pleasant for the
the short-term but is actually going to
lead to greater pains or why certain
pains actually ought to be endured in
the short term so that we can have
greater pleasure in the long term if you
don't have that sort of orientation
you're going to make bad decisions which
are going to lead to you not actually
living pleasantly and probably not you
know honorably probably not even justly
also if you live a life that is lacking
in justice if you decide well I'm going
to cheat I'm going to lie I'm going to
steal I'm going to subvert the norms
Epicurus actually thinks you can never
be totally sure that you're going to get
away with it you might actually be
bothered by the fact that you're doing
that sort of stuff you know you maybe
you feel pangs of conscience that would
be pains that would be lack of pleasure
but he thinks that those who do wrong in
general you have to live in a state of
fear so if you don't live justly then
you're going to live unpleasantly it's
an interesting question could you live
prudently without living justly or could
you live honorably without living justly
I think Epicurus would probably say no
in those cases that's not really going
to to be sustainable maybe in the short
term yes but not not in the long term so
all three of these are required as not
only conditions for the pleasant life
you might say a certain set of
components or dimensions of the pleasant
life but they're also what's productive
of the pleasant life acting justly
allows you to live in a matrix of
relationships with human beings who are
going to think that you're a jerk and
won't distrust you and won't want to
punish you when they find out the sort
of bad things that you've done right
acting prudently will permit you to
decide you know what things to pursue
and what things to avoid and they will
interface you might say your intersect
with each other in a life that is truly
Pleasant and Epicurus thinks that that's
going to be a life
the virtues where these are you might
say ways of living virtuously